Chris Lozinski wired contributor here
showing you how to push a coin through a
table very simple all you need is a coin
you just tap it II tap like that and it
goes right through the table amazed no
it's almost a little kids trick really
this is using a little thing called
lapping and so I'll give you a quick run
through I'm just letting the coin drop
off the edge of the table when I slide
it back like that and then when I'm
tapping on the table I'm really just
tapping right below with the coin that's
falling back there so in a little more
depth you know we'll get some details
here going you basically are just gonna
pull the coin to the edge of the table
and this is the move that I'm
approximating is just picking up the
coin actually off the table so that's a
good way to practice it you can just do
this all day but as you'll notice when I
go to pick up the coin I kind of
naturally bring my thumb in so that's
another thing you do is you kind of just
bring your thumb against your hand like
so at the edge of the table and then let
it fall onto the other hand and then I
just go underneath you might want to say
something intelligent as you like
gesture upward with the coin like I have
a blog or something on it and then tap
try to time your tappings properly right
and then you can slide you can do all
sorts of fancy noises and then snap the
coin on the bottom and reveal what has
just happened
they'll be astonished will get lots of
dates